[Music]
from our past videos we note that light
follows law of reflection after being
incident on a surface just like the
light waves sound waves also get
reflected from the surface of a solid
they also follow the same law of
reflection let us see what that law is
say we have our source which is emitting
sound and assume one of the sound wave
strikes the surface at this point let's
draw a normal to this surface normal is
nothing but the line which is
perpendicular to the surface at the
point of incidence now this wave will be
reflected from the surface the law of
reflection tells us that this sound wave
will be reflected back in such a way
that the angle of incidence I is equal
to the angle of reflection are also the
incident ray the reflected ray and the
normal will all lie in the same plane
what if a wave is incident perpendicular
to the surface well in that case the
reflected sound will travel back in the
opposite direction along the same line
here is one demonstration that you can
perform at home to verify these laws
take two small hollow cylindrical shaped
objects which are open from both ends do
straight hollow pipes with suffice place
them on the table like this near the
wall we also need to make sure that the
table is covered with a white cardboard
paper before keeping the pipes on it
place a running clock near the open end
of the pipe facing you and now keep your
you're near the open end of the other
pipe did you hear the sound of the
tick's coming from the pipe adjust the
pipes a little until the sound is
clearer at one point it will be very
clear this is an example of reflection
of sound yes you are hearing the
reflected sound the sound wave from the
clock passes through this pipe and is
incident on the wall it gets reflected
and passes through the other pipe and
enters your ear you will notice that
these two angles are approximately equal
the angle of incidence will be equal to
the angle of reflection
if we ignore any human errors echo is
another example where one is able to
hear the reflected sound what is an echo
the repetition of the same sound again
and again is what we call it echo where
do we hear an echo well we usually hear
it in empty spaces mounted by at least
one tall surface for example when we're
inside a large Canyon or when we are
shouting in a deep empty well from above
if we clap in an open space standing
against a tall wall we will also hear
the sound of our clap again and again
[Applause]
why does it happen the sound from a clap
travels in all the possible directions
when it collides with the obstacle it
gets reflected back these reflected
sound waves then travel towards us and
we hear faint repetitions of our clap
again and again but hold on are there
any conditions or will we hear an echo
in any and every case yes there are a
few conditions the echo depends on the
temperature of the surroundings and the
distance between you and a point of
reflection let me give you an example
assume that the temperature of the
surroundings is approximately 22 degrees
Celsius at this temperature the distance
between you and the wall has to be at
least 17 point 2 meters for you to hear
an echo only if it's equal to or greater
than 17 two-point meters you may hear an
echo otherwise you wouldn't but why did
we have this condition what if the
temperature is different what if the
distance is less than 17 point 2 meters
are there any other conditions apart
from temperature and distance we will
answer these questions in our next video
[Music]